[Musique]
quoi
[Applaudissements]
nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui pour la
quatrième édition de nos déjeuners de
livres in business club et nous avons
une chance incroyable aujourd'hui nous
accueillons patrick puy qui est le pdg
du groupe vivarte est un monsieur k
redresser multiples grands groupes
notamment arc par exemple et donc pour
un moment de convivialité avec les
dirigeants des yvelines
patrick lui merci infiniment d'être
parmi nous donc l'objectif c'est de
d'avoir cet échange se partagent et afin
de mieux vous connaître
j'ai préparé une slide alors ce serait
c'est pas du tout exhaustif ça serait
très compliqué une carrière vraiment
exceptionnel je vous laisse évidemment
la parole pour ce nous donner en fait
une vue sur votre carrière votre vision
est très rapide g22 moment dans ma
carrière le premier de qui va jusqu'en
2000 qui est une carrière normale si je
puis dire dans des groupes normaux avec
une vision long terme
deux employeurs au fond tout berger et
legrand dont j'étais directeur général à
limoges pendant dix ans
et puis après j'ai pris la présidence de
moulinex a failli est un chasseur de
tête il m'a appelé en 2002 l'a dit
patrick mouly naji ça va pas non plus
fous inondant moulinex adossé à brantes
c'était un projet qui était pas idiot
j'ai regardé je pensais que cette est
sauvable j'y suis allé et puis les
actionnaires italiens de brandon ont pas
voulu refinancer le plan donc dépôt de
bilan très très médiatisée à l'époque
très très douloureux et après j'étais
tenu sulfureux pour la vraie vie je ne
pouvais pas voir personne voulait
m'embaucher
en plus j'ai été mis en examen pendant
14 ans j'ai été évidemment relaxé mais
ça dure un peu longtemps et c'est un peu
douloureux et donc après ça je me suis
dit soit je fais de l'art postmoderne
soit je capitalise sur l'expérience de
la restructuration
j'ai choisi la deuxième voie tant pis
pour l'art et dans cette voie là bas
j'ai créé d'abord alvarez marsal en
france avec ce
ce chapeau j'aime restructurer smoby
vogica centre d'entreprises mais des
petites aussi un gainsbourg mais en
france ça faisait 25 millions et puis
après à lee kyou-hyuk lee management et
dans ce cadre là j'ai re structuré arc
dont j'étais le président pendant un an
et demi ce pire est maintenant vivarte
dont je suis encore le président même si
je viens d'embaucher un directeur
général qui lui va bosser sur la
restructuration est finie et moi je pars
vers d'autres aventures
vous vous pourrez nous donner ce scoop
ou pas j'ai signé hier la présidence de
famars est un groupe pharmaceutique de
un petit groupe de 500 millions et 12 12
usines qui est dans une mer de noir pour
être clair ça veut dire quoi
concrètement vers le noir ça veut dire
que l'on sait pas faire la paix engagé
je suis président depuis hier je suis
quand même venu aujourd'hui alors que
j'étais convoqué à bercy et j'en
remercie beaucoup parce que vraiment ça
a été très difficile et on sait pas
faire la paye de joueurs donc c'est ça
la béance voir ça c'est important parce
que dans dans la préparation de notre
déjeuner aujourd'hui nous allons y
revenir par d'autres sly mais moi
j'avais notion de crise et j'ai appris
beaucoup en peu des changes
là c'est une crise c'est une vraie crise
ah oui oui quand on sait pas faire le
pas voilà c'est important parce que y en
a mais en même temps je suis conseiller
de bourbon bourbon c'est le le leader
mondial des bateaux approvisionneurs
pour les plateformes pétrolières
j'ai divorcé quand je suis arrivé 3
milliards de dettes 50 millions d'ebitda
ça marche pas bien donc on m'a demandé
de gérer ça donc j'ai ramené la tête à
300 millions relativement beau succès et
donc bourbon ils ont 3 milliards de
dettes et 100 millions d'ebitda donc ils
m'ont appelé ils ont dit est ce que tu
sais à rené ramener la dette à 300
millions
mais bon qui ne sont pas contents que
quand j'arrive mais autrefois c'étaient
les syndicats n'étaient pas contents
parce qu'il restructurait socialo
maintenant je restructure financièrement
alors donc la majorité du temps ça
fonctionne dès fois moins l'intérêt de
la restructuration c'était un métier qui
étaient à bord qui était inconnu en
france et puis et puis qui était mal
apprécié c'était le failli yahia ya
cinquante ans c'était le patron qui
avait fait faillite et c'était il été
mis au ban de la société
aujourd'hui c'est les lois ont changé
les lois de 85 de 2005 et les banques
ont changé le support des pouvoirs
publics a changé quel que soit leur bord
donc aujourd'hui c'est plus on a moins
honte d'être malade et ton qu'on soigne
plus facilement et on sauve toujours
cela cependant il ya des moments où on
sauve pas vogica g passe j'ai pas sauver
c'était très abîmé fabrice est pas sauvé
non plus et dans ce cas l'on peut
déposer le bilan
et puis on passe la main du trader jeudi
si un accord alors heureusement beaucoup
de succès et non des moindres oui la
plupart du temps on a le roi est malade
on a le droit est malade ça nous arrive
à tous et il faut se soigner
la première chose quand on doit soigner
c'est d'être conscient qu'on est malade
parce que ce soit quand on est une
entreprise malade on veut pas le savoir
pour des raisons simples parce que ça
met en cause ce qu'on a fait
précédemment
on est obligé de se remettre en cause
remettre en cause des actionnaires dans
votre cause le management de remettre en
cause de soi même donc c'est compliqué
mais la plupart du temps si on peut agir
assez vite
eh ben on soigne et ce mobile c'est un
des trucs dont je suis le plus fier
parce qu'on a licencié 1350 personnes
deux ans après la boîte à réembaucher
650 de ses licenciés c'est dans le jura
c'est pas mal c'est énorme
donc nous nous poursuivons et là c'est
une autre réussite et vous l'avez
fier donc là on nous avons notre actuel
président qui ne l'était pas à l'époque
attendant tant dans le débat de macron
avec marine le pen il manquerait en
haïti qui l'avait sauvé arc
moi je pensais que c'est moi qui l'avais
fait mais du coup on a développé des
relations ça peut servir pour parler
d'arc justement qualité la plus grosse
difficulté puisque c'est pas forcément
celle qu'on qu'on attend dans une
entreprise
est ce que c'était les syndicats les
salariés le l'actionnaire éventuellement
alors vous êtes tous des chefs
d'entreprise
et si vous êtes confronté à des
difficultés je vous engage à réfléchir à
quelle est calé lequel est le frein quel
est le point le plus faible et c'est
vrai que françois vous avez raison il ya
il y a des partenaires il ya les banques
il ya l'état il ya les syndicats il ya
le management
eyal actionnaires et la plupart du temps
j'ai trouvé des difficultés avec celui
que j'attendais pas c'était un
actionnaire parce que lui il est surtout
axé leur vie familiale
donc ça leur met tellement en cause je
suis arrivé on n'a pas de quoi faire la
paye j'ai fait un truc assez formidable
et puis 3 - la boîte été sauvées et donc
les mises en était saoul et
temporairement gelé mise en vente avec
l'accord des actionnaires bien sûr mais
au fond d'eux-mêmes et est le cerveau
droit qu'accepter le cerveau gauche qui
acceptaient pas et ils n'ont pas arrêté
de me mettre des bâtons dans les roues
ils ont voulu virer ils ont espionné ma
boîte ma boite mail pas des trucs des
rapporte un contre un président et son
conseil où sont ses actionnaires bon à
la fin ça c'est bien fini mais mais
c'est toujours très compliqué et si vous
voulez sauver un jour votre boîte qui
est en difficulté ce que j'espère que
non mais dites vous bien que le 1 je
vous engage à embaucher un professionnel
de la restructuration parce que vous
êtes trop émotionnellement impliqués
dans ce qui s'est passé 2 faites lui
confiance
et revenez quand la loi sera sauvé j'ai
vu ça chez arc j'ai vu ça chez spirent
l'actionnaire était tellement impliqué
qui voulait pas qu'ils voulaient pas
accepté leur difficile restructuration
il faut faut même om 36 mois de vacances
donc pas hésité à disparaître alors nous
allons revenir sur certaines parce que
c'est très important est de pouvoir est
partagé alors là on parle beaucoup de
crises ou quand ça va pas on va aussi
vous entendre sur give au vert pour que
ça aille bien
ça va être aussi important et vous avez
mentionné
des décisions difficiles parfois
douloureuses j'ai noté ce score là 10000
postes supprimés trente mille postes
sauvés sur l'espace de 2 combien
d'années dit no 15 en hausse 15 ans
voilà le sentiment que ça vous laisse
parce que parfois c'est ce sur quoi vous
êtes attaqués
non j'ai pas le sentiment d'être
attaquée d'ailleurs françois si on
m'attaque y est je me retournerai pour
ça qu'ils vous parler mais pas à moi
enfin je suis pas attaquable mais je le
ferai pas parce que bon la carrure et
puis le côté rugby par là par là je veux
dire que quand on fait ça il faut il
faut vraiment se désape leaké alors et
dans mes proches me disent que je suis
un monstre de froideur mais met pas tout
est vrai il faut se les appliquer parce
que si vous commencez à regarder dans le
blanc des yeux les dix militaires ce que
vous a licencié que vous en vous en
sentez coupable
ben vous n'avancez pas et il faut
procéder à ces licenciements l'a donc
des implications
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas le faire
avec respect quand vous licencier
quelqu'un il faut pas lui dire je te
licencie pas ce qu'on m'a demandé de le
faire
faut lui dire j'ai décidé que parce que
si vous voulez dit on m'a demandé de le
faire le conseil d'administration bla
bla bla bla le débat s'arrête mais
pourquoi est on va pleurer vous cherchez
la compréhension de l'autre qui pourra
vous donner
si oui j'ai décidé que le débat ça va
pas être pourquoi ça va être combien et
c'est beaucoup plus froid c'est beaucoup
plus clinique ça va beaucoup plus vite
et c'est beaucoup plus respectueux donc
assumer et puis faire face et puis
surtout il ya aussi en fait la
restructuration et le développement
d'emplois et la sauvegarde mais on est
tous des chefs d'entreprise on a tous
donc des employés et on connaît tous les
lois qui nous oblige à protéger les
emplois malheureusement en france on
protège pas les emplois en protège les
employés et c'est assez radicalement
différente où tous les pays ont des lois
qui protègent les emplois nous en france
auprès on protège les employés présents
au détriment d'une fluidité du marché de
l'emploi
et c'est ça qui fait qu'à la fin on se
retrouve avec 10% de chômeurs eux c'est
le seul pays où le de l'eau c'est dieu
qui est ce taux de chômage
on voit par l'espagnol
alors lors de la préparation et je vous
remercie infiniment d'avoir été très
direct avec moi j'ai noté des moments
marquants
j'entends par là des dates j'ai retenu
des dates que vous m'avez donné je les
ai pas prises ailleurs
donc ça vient vraiment de vous 4 mai
2004 qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour nos
pour tous et surtout pour vous la
déconfiture de moulinex était en 2001 la
justice a avancé et le 4 mai alors
j'avais un contrat avec alstom j'étais
patron de l'activité hydro terre les
barrages et ça m'emmerde et alstom une
trop grosse boîte je voudrais pour
schneider mai mais un peu moins pour
alstom et et j'ai rejoint le jeu créé le
cabinet alvarez & marsal en france et
leucate je le crée j'étais mission d'al
sommes le 1er mai je créais lgv arrive
en salle le 1er mai le 4 mai fut mis en
examen et les américains il n'aime pas
trop c'est un responsable c'est un
groupe américain the black keys n'aime
pas trop ça ils m'appellent à new york
et il dit
tu vois ton contrat bois pour le
déchirent je sortais de trois ans de
difficultés quand même pas avec la
justice et tout ça et j'ai j'avais
toujours aux mains plus de contrat je
passe presque passer quelques moments du
c'était le 17 mai le 4 mai c'est la mise
en examen doit renoncer la garde à vue
alors sur un moment rigolo mais
recommande d'éviter avec dédé des flics
un peu insupportable et des tentative
d'humiliation
mais quand on est sportif et surtout
quand on a fait son devoir on s'en fout
c'est pas le sujet et donc le 17 mai les
américains déchire votre contrat devant
vous quelle est votre réaction
comment vous faites pour changer la
situation bah là aussi la tentation de
l'art postmoderne m'a pris mais j'ai
toujours pas cédé et donc on a négocié
pendant des heures et je suis sortie de
quatre heures après avec un autre
contrainte
donc du coup laventure alvarez peut se
mettre en place et j'ai noté également
des rencontres
parce que la vie c'est beaucoup c'est
également et thé visage
[Musique]
voilà c'était mon premier patron chez
schubert g c'est un type à qui j'ai
menti parce qu'un jour je voulais une
boîte qui était sous traitantes qui
faisait des bancs de tests produits
électroniques qui fait faillite et
vouloir acheter
et je lui complètement menti et plus
haute est tout gamin est évidemment il a
vu que j'avais menti
mais plutôt que de me sanctionner il m'a
pressé encouragé dans mon mensonge et y
est imam il m'a soutenu dans
l'acquisition un peu olé olé de ces
entreprises et le le pardon dans
l'entreprise faire grandir dans les gens
dans l'entreprise c'est aussi vrai dans
la vie privée c'est ces cétacés
formateur un autre visage une autre
personne
rené ricol et rené c2c le patron des
commissaires aux comptes mondiaux mais
pendant longtemps et commissaire au plan
et rené c'était le seul dans l'histoire
moulinex à me défendre vraiment et il
est pas là mais merci rené donc cette
importance de ce que j'entends aussi
vous vous gardez en vous cette main
tendue finalement ou en tout cas ses
encouragements
oui et parce que il ya des valeurs
morales dans notre vie de même quand on
fait de la restructuration avec les
choses difficiles même contre licencie
du monde on peut et on doit être moral
mais il ya d'autres jettent autre
exemple à jour je vais j'avais
il y avait un type c'est extraordinaire
c'est plat pierre vaio qui était le
patron de total exploration production
qui téléphonent à l'école polytechnique
ou gt gt président du bureau des élèves
et il demande à me rencontrer à tignes
avec moi pour pour sas qui vous dire aux
élèves pour leur faire un empire aux
tapes et je t'ai d'une prétention total
d'une arrogance ans dont jeunes kong et
jeudi écouté mon vieux venait dîner à
palaiseau et pointait le jour je suis
arrivée avec une heure de retard en
grand uniforme
parce que dans le même jour c'est le
bicorne l'épée ça parce que le même jour
j'ai rencontré pierre weill aucun type
extraordinaire et j'étais en retard
parce que j'avais rendez vous avec just
jacqueline ça vous dit rien mais les
plus âgés d'entre vous savent que c'est
le producteur du film emmanuelle et le
film était classé x et on peut pas faire
de pub avec un film classé x
il avait gagné avait fait un procès il a
gagné le procès est donc il a téléphoné
à l'école polytechnique pour devenir en
est le plus bel élèves de la promo x en
tenue du grand uniforme pour proposer
avec les manuels et donc j'avais dit pas
de problème je vous l'envoie et bien sûr
l'issue aller moi-même et donc dans le
même jour j'ai rencontré pierre vaio et
sylvia kristel paix à son âme
puisqu'elle est décédé depuis alors le
là nous pouvons donc maintenant
profitez de votre présence pour entendre
l'expérience vivarte donc là ce sont des
chiffres c'est des constats comment vous
allez trouver cette entreprise quand
vous êtes arrivé à l'époque elle faisait
3 milliards de tête un milliard huit
deux chiffres et 54 millions de vie doit
donc c'est une catastrophe
pourquoi pas parce que le retail marche
pas très bien en france le retail et
pattaya pas de banque est ici pascal
n'était pas obligé de répondre mais les
banques ne soutiennent pas du tout le
retail en france alors que ça fait vivre
trois millions de français
et puis parce que vivarte s'est
développée sur un modèle développé par
plassac et est la juxtaposition
d'entreprises sur le territoire national
les entreprises qui marchent dans le
retail c'est le contraire ceara qui
développe mondialement un modèle donc
c'était c'était donc une tête excessive
alors j'ai fait j'ai restructurer la
dette fait un plan de réorganisation sur
toute la halle et donc de fermeture des
usines deux usines de 2,2 magasin avec
un plan social à des attaques
et puis vendu des actifs j'avais 16 ans
saigne un groupe qui fait 54 millions
qu'à 16 enseignes c'est pas possible ça
fait 3 millions par enseigne et le rôle
d'un chef d'entreprise c'est pas d'avoir
une grosse taille c'est de donner aux
entreprises qui sont les nôtres les
moyens de se développer y lire des
lettres aujourd'hui le camp quand vous
prenez la main sur un dossier comme
celui ci
la première semaine qui est quel est le
plan de bataille faut tout de suite
identifier ceux qui se font pas en
travers de la restructuration et ceux
qui seront en travers pas de pitié parce
que quand on fait une bataille il faut
être loyal et les équipes qui sont pas
loyal elles sortent elles sortent tout
de suite donc faut parler faut écouter
parce que le vrai charisme c'est pas de
parler c'est d'écouter
c'est le type qui ressort de votre
bureau avec les cités que vous aviez ça
prouve que vous avez et du charisme il
faut aller voir les banquiers faut aller
voir les syndicats font les aurait pu
rayonner les pouvoirs publics et vous
dormez pas mais la première semaine est
les clés parce que à la fin de la
première semaine vous savez que vous
allez passer deux ou trois mois que vous
avez les finances pour passer de trois
mois parce que la clé c'est le cash
évident est que après vous avez le temps
de faire un vrai plan de restructuration
d'accord alors donc là c'est les
chiffres qui sont qui sont redonné donc
ce que nous avons pu voir ensemble
là on parle beaucoup de constats de
finalement il ya des causes pour arriver
à des situations comme ça comment on en
sort donc là les solutions en fait pour
sortir tout ça vous avez plus une
entreprise est en crise plus c'est
simple d'identifier le business plan
pour repos en sortir parce que à moins
que ce soit pas sauvabelin s'il ya un
changement technologique majeure etc
mais sinon une crise grave elle résulte
de d'erreurs graves
donc on les identifie et on les résoudre
c'est extrêmement simple chez vivarte 3
milliards de dettes 54 millions d'ebita
il n'était pas très compliqué si on
réduisait pas la dette ne s'en sortait
pas donc j'ai convoqué les 172 banquiers
landaise et on est plus d'actionner un
steak que des fonds de tête
et puis j'arrive vous avez tout perdu ou
vous écraser sur 90 % de votre tête vous
avez tout perdu
ça met un peu de temps avant de
rencontrer dans les esprits mais à la
ccsa l'électrochoc vis-à-vis d'un abat
d'abord quand tu arrives quelqu'un qui
est spécialiste de restes de la
restructuration d'entreprise c'est déjà
un électrochoc et c'est la prise de
conscience que les choses vont mal il
n'y a pas que moi qui fais ce métier en
france y en a d'autres et on arrive les
syndicats il affiche votre portrait sur
le mur qui jouent aux fléchettes dessus
est bon la crise est là
l'électrochoc eva et c'est un
électrochoc positif et alors j'ai une
question qui me taraude parce que c'est
là j'ai le plaisir d'être parmi vous et
beaucoup d'implication dans ce club mais
il m'arrive de travailler également
chaque fois sur mon propre métier donc
et moi ce qui m'a tassé à dimension
business et je me dis mais là on
redresse la dette j'ai l'occasion de
travailler sur un dossier de
retournement et parfois les financiers
oublie le business c'est à dire que si
on recommence les mêmes causes
produiront les mêmes effets qu'est ce
qui se passe sur l'aspect positionnement
de marque démarche plutôt business
comment vous voyez les choses à chaque
fois qu'on fait de leur restructuration
il faut aussi montrer qu'elle est la
lumière au bout du tunnel
et donc il faut reparler business parce
que les finances est une chose mais ça
suffit pas donc il faut soit redéfinir
la stratégie mais quand on fait de la
restructuration
on n'a pas le temps on n'a pas
d'intelligence et on n'a pas d'argent
donc on peut même acheter de
l'intelligence avec tes cabinet mckinsey
bcg de ça donc on est obligé d'aller
très vite et sans changer la stratégie
montré que en résolvant les problèmes au
bout du tunnel il ya de la lumière
et après on va affiner mais ça nécessite
aussi que toutes les semaines on doit
dire on vous avait dit qu'on serait là
et on est là et que iliad et milestone
sur lesquels on avance et c'est ça qui
donne confiance et après on peut
recommencer à avoir une stratégie est
très certainement en ayant vendu des
actifs et notamment les actifs les plus
sains parce que si vous ne les activent
pas ça s'arrête donc là on prend
quelques chiffres par les démarques les
marques qui sont restés
aujourd'hui qui sont encore fortes au
sein du groupe bah il ne reste plus que
cinq marques drop la halle carole
minnelli san marina cosmoparis j'ai mis
les trois dernières en vente il ya trois
mois quatre mois et il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'appétit donc si vous voulez
acheter une marque dell ne faut sur
besoin après le déjeuner et alors nous
avons parlé tout à l'heure de des
actionnaires et puis parfois il ya aussi
des des interactions avec le politique
comment s'est passée justement il me
semble que vous avez une réunion éclair
ou n'étaient pas éclaircies
j'ai dû être nommé jeu pas de 2 ou 3
novembre et puis le 6 ou 7 novembre
myriam échos briquettes amis du travail
à l'époque déclare la presse qu' elle a
convoqué le président du gart et effrayé
par le plan de restructuration sociale
abominable qui allait faire ce grand
france henri capital et le soir donc
j'entends salariaux et le soir twister
du soir je reçois un coup de fil c'était
le secrétariat de telles conneries qui
me dit monsieur le président ce que je
peux passer même le mm oui et je me dis
parce que j'ai bien conscience quels
effets de caudry quoi enfin pas
politiser pas très poli mais vous avez
vu que je vous demandait de venir me
voir mardi prochain 8 heures et moi je
dis mardi mardi
je peux pas j'ai piscine
et elle était bonne mais comme c'est une
femme c'est assez habile et s'est bien
rendu compte que 1 je plaisantais et que
de l avait dépassé les bornes
mais faut montrer il faut montrer les
crocs avec ces gens là ont des tenues
très copain avec myriam el khomri très
copains c'est une femme formidable mais
mais il faut montrer les crocs parce
qu'ils se croient tout permis
ils ont une connaissance du monde
industriel extrêmement faible et je
félicite vaut d'autres associations
parce que c'est à travers cet héros là
qu'on fait prendre conscience aux gens
que l'industrie de l'entreprise
c'est un territoire compliqué c'est un
territoire créateurs de richesse est un
territoire créateur de bonheur et ces
gens là ne savent pas d'accord merci en
tout cas alors quand vous prenez les
commandes
là j'ai noté des points mais quel est le
plan alors déjà j'ai entendu à plusieurs
fois une notion de timing il ya un
aspect de temps est ce que c'est vrai
c'est l'urgence et c'est vraiment un
facteur déterminant et puis quels sont
les autres clés général quand on
s'appelle des gens comme moi c'est que
on est au bord de la mort donc c'est
très urgent et c'est très urgent pour
autant faut prendre du temps je pense
que vous rappelez churchill après la
bataille d'el alamein il était deux
heures de l'après-midi à ses généraux
qui disent les soeurs ont perdu la
bataille qu'est ce que vous allez faire
chercher regarde sa montre il était 2h y
moi la sieste et et quelquefois faut
prendre du temps et notamment dans la
première phase d'information réflexion
action la première phase d'information
et de partage du du diagnostic
2 pourquoi ça va mal et comment on va
s'en sortir elle elle doit être assez
approfondies c'est à dire que toutes les
expériences que j'ai vécues qui ont
échoué
vogica fabrice c'est parce que on
n'avait pas assez partagée avec
l'ensemble des intervenants le
diagnostic et les interventions des
intervenants ces les pouvoirs publics
les banques et syndicats les
actionnaires
donc ça ça doit être très partagés parce
qu'une fois que c'est partagé après dans
la phase de réflexion pour établir le
ppc pas très compliqué et puis la phase
d'action lll doit être hyper rapide
hyper forte et vous devez pas dévié de
votre de votre
chemin je pense que vous vous rappelez
descarpentries qui était patron de de
quoi carnaudmetalbox et d'autres choses
et il disait prendre une décision et
rend la bonne et alors c'est excessif
mais mais quand on fait de la
restructuration on prend une décision et
on change pas alors là on parle beaucoup
de crises de quand ça va mal très bien
l'idée en tout cas est ce que je
souhaite à tous ici aujourd'hui pour nos
entreprises c'est que ça aille bien
alors qu'est-ce que quand on traite
beaucoup la crise on arrive à trouver
des bonnes vision que je suis persuadé
que oui alors lesquels quels conseils
donneriez-vous aux patrons qui sont ici
non ça ce serait prétentieux parce que
moi je sais gérer que la crise donc je
je je sais pas avant je gérais le grand
quand même pendant dix ans et long terme
adhésion du personnel mais ce que disait
bruno et c'est très bien différenciation
on ne gagne rien s'il ya pas de
différenciation et puis on ne gagne rien
si on pense pas que les hommes sont pas
les éléments clés mais mais après me
conseille s'arrête là je peux vous
donner des conseils si vous êtes en
crise mais papa pas beaucoup plus ce que
j'ai retenu aussi et ce qui est un
indicateur que les gens voient mais ne
prennent pas complètement en compte ce
que vous avez dit très important je
pense qu'il faut leur préciser c'est le
cash
c'est à dire que souvent il ya même
comme je dirais du déni du dirigeant
c'est ça commence à aller mal les
indicateurs que quelques et la manière
concrète
quels sont pour vous les indicateurs qui
disent attention là il faut vraiment
prendre le taureau par les cornes
alors quand on est malade c'est le
thermomètre et le cash c'est le terreau
est l'entreprise ça je vais pas vous
l'apprendre je vais pas vous l'apprendre
mais votre cash baisse un peu plus que
ce que vous aviez prévu pour des raisons
que vous connaissez pas et vous allez
pas faire attention et six mois après
vous avez vous en mordre les doigts
quand le cash baisse et que c'était pas
prévu c'est a manifestement la preuve
qu' un problème qui qui est qui qui va
surgir et l'info aller très vite
et là faut pas se dire demain c'est
demain servira j'ai connu des chefs
d'entreprise du coach serge van bergen a
dit formidable et qui a monté son fonds
après être sorti de chez pinault
j'avais restructuring boîte pour lui et
au bout d'un certain temps je dis qu'il
faudrait faire plus loin faudrait faire
plus fort et me dit non non tu vas voir
et puis et puis le miracle arrive tôt
elle arrive pas n'arrive jamais jamais
donc faut pas être optimiste chef
d'entreprise c'est quelqu'un d'optimiste
mais on rappelait saint-augustin il
disait il faut se méfier
cependant se méfier et est un péché ne
pas se méfier d'une connerie et et je
crois qu'il faut se méfier il faut être
optimiste mais se méfier je pense que
c'est en tout cas intéressant et très
très éprouvant avant que que nous vous
que vous puissiez aussi vous restaurez
parce que c'est important
nous avons aussi le plus cité prend le
dessert le but du jeu est vraiment là
c'est très ouvert
il nous reste du temps je vois que notre
président est impatient de pose une
question laurent oui vous avez dit tout
à l'heure le redressement d'entreprises
avant c'était le social et maintenant
c'est le financier comment vous
expliquer ce changement
le financier a pris une part très
importante parce que très sincèrement en
france on se plaint tous deux du coût du
travail et des charges mais en réalité
par rapport à il ya 20 ans la part des
salaires dans le pib a baissé
qu'est ce qui augmente aujourd'hui les
matières premières ne compte plus son
bar yam et donc menti fondamentalement
plus le coût du travail baisse le coût
de l'argent augmente le coût de l'argent
augmente beaucoup alors pas dans les
entreprises très saine ou si vous avez à
titre personnel des fortunes vous avez
vous avez le placer à la banque à 0 3%
en maxi mais si vous êtes en une reprise
en difficulté vous allez voir votre
banquier
désolé monsieur manqué et il va vous
faire ou que c'est le taux de la tête de
vivarte 13,25 %
bah oui pourtant les taux n'ont jamais
été aussi bas oui mais les banquiers et
et je leur en veux pas les banquiers
français ils sont contraints par une loi
française qui s'appelle la gestion de
fait hors observons que le dernier et
banquiers à avoir été condamné pour ça
c'était la sphère pas la sterne en 1995
mais les banquiers sont des gens
intelligents je me rattrape
ils ont la mémoire et et dans la sphère
moulinex ils ont été attrait en justice
ils n'ont pas été condamnées mise en
théâtre et est donc le banquier français
il se méfie parce qu' il ne peut pas
être gestionnaire de fait et donc il
prend des précautions et si l'afer est
en difficulté regardez tout le retail en
france et dans les grandes difficultés
parce que les pompiers de financement
alors c'est vrai et libertés mais c'est
beaucoup plus vrai de cabaye e ikks bla
bla bla bla bla
trois questions merci s'il vous plaît
dans des périodes aussi courte que celle
de la gestion de crise
quelles actions pouvaient vous revoir
sur les ventes parce que quand une
entreprise va mal
très souvent c'est il ya plus de vente
où il ya moins de vente et donc dans des
périodes assez fulgurante comme vous
nous avez décrit qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
alors dans la boîte que je préside
depuis hier famars
la première chose que je vais faire
c'est de voir les salariés la deuxième
chose c'est de venir vous voir vous et
la troisième c'est les voir les clients
parce que faut associer les clients la
restructuration et les clients de famars
et le sanofi gsk fise etc
je vais leur demander du pognon et ils
vont me le donner et et ils vont être
associés à la restructuration et tout
laissait gagnant gagnant donc là sûr pas
le développement des ventes pour
l'éternité mais j'assure le lien fort
entre clients et entreprises
oui je pense que ça a un côté rassurant
pour les clients au final que deux que
d'avoir des informations positives parce
que le pire c'est l'affolement c'est de
ne pas savoir la la la déclaration de
l'information positive et est très forte
oui monsieur puis vous avez expliqué que
pour retrouver du cache en fait vous
avez vendu des actifs qui marchait bien
donc j'imagine les marques qui marchait
bien mais si vous vendez finalement ce
qui a de la valeur et ce qui marche bien
il vous reste plus que les tocards
comment est ce qu'on fait pour retour
remonter une entreprise où il ya plus de
deux forces vives
finalement votre question est très
vicieuse mais faux faux pas d'abord il
n'y a pas beaucoup de tocards première
bourre deuxièmement mon message était
très simple il faut il faut aussi vendre
des actifs qui sont sains prenons un
autre exemple alstom patrick kron
quand la crise chez alstom a commencé il
a vendu ce qui marchait bien c'est à
dire toute la partie et de general
electric et la partie qui marchait moins
bien le ferroviaire il l'a gardée et
avec l'argent de ce qu'il a vendu il a
restructuré la partie c'est ça qu'il
faut faire
gj arte on a vendu mercal qui marchait
bien en espagne en a vendu besson qui
marche très très bien
et puis on a gardé des choses qui
marchent très bien aussi carole sera
très bientôt
c'est un mélange lait en tout cas si si
j'ai fait une faute c'est moulinex c'est
que j'ai pas voulu vendre krups et j'ai
eu tort
le même le même homme de 20 ans après on
aurait tout de suite en du groupe ce qui
était une marque formidable donc faut
pas hésiter
et si vous êtes en faillite personnelle
bien vous n'allez pas vendre votre les
deux chevaux vous allez vendre votre
rôle ce n'est pas drôle d'ailleurs il me
semble alors j'ai une question vous
acceptez de manière personnelle vous
avez dit que j'ai noté que vous avez des
périodes très difficiles vous avez vous
même été obligé de te taper dans
patrimoine
personnellement oui en 2000
en 2000 un dépôt de bilan et après je
n'étais pas été embauchés
j'étais encore toujours prétentieux donc
je me disais oh pas de problème en un
grand brochet demain matin tiens j'ai
passé deux ans même pas au chômage parce
qu'elle était président donc y avait pas
de chômage
j'avais pas de vieillesse c'est ce que
j'aime pas ce que c'est que ce que ça
existait et de vous engager à la voir et
c'est l'assurance des chefs d'entreprise
pour ceux qui savent pas pour le chômage
et que pour le nom en activité il faut
la voir
et donc j'ai passé deux ans sans aucun
revenu alors par chance une femme qui
continuent à dépenser beaucoup ce qui
m'a obligé à avoir confiance et donc
j'ai aujourd'hui effectivement olhao
bord de mer autre question bonjour
monsieur
comment vous expliquez auriez la
différence entre l'allemagne et la
france en ce qui concerne l'industrie et
le développement des sociétés on a
toujours l'impression que nous on est en
retard d'une guerre ou qui se développe
plus rapidement que nos ou que les
relations sociales sont plus apaisé ou
que les banques les suivent d'une façon
plus plus pérenne sans en ayant moins de
règles et nous on a toujours
l'impression qu'on a plus de règles plus
de deux barrières syndicale plus de
l'environnement et puis finalement bas
alors je sais que c'est quoi
l'explication entre la france et
l'allemagne pourquoi il ya cet écart où
on a quand même temps
parce que la question est très vaste et
très longue et c'est entre la france et
l'allemagne c'est entre la france et
tous les pays de ces deux là france est
un cas particulier et abyan moi je
continue de penser que malgré toutes les
dispositions qui sont pas nécessairement
mauvaise qu'ils ont prises depuis deux
ans à la fin rien n'est fait pour
contrôler la dépense publique et et pour
la limiter et donc cette dépense
publique elle va être financé par qui
mais par vous par les entreprises les
charges qui pèsent sur les entreprises
de ce point de vue là sont intolérables
simplement intolérable et en france nous
avons six millions de fonctionnaires
un peu plus d'un fonctionnaire nationaux
peu plus de deux fonctionnaires
hospitaliers habilité à un plus de deux
fonctionnaires territoriaux en allemagne
à quatre millions et demi de
fonctionnaires pour une population qui
est un peu plus grande l'écart s'est
donc 2 millions de fonctionnaires à
30000 un peu plus haut ça fait 100
milliards et la france manque de quoi
200 mais si on a les 100 milliards de
plus en france c'est exactement ce qui
nous manque je rappelle que le budget
d'état c'est 400 milliards de dépense
300 milliards de recettes innovantes
sont mia et 700 milliards on les a alors
vous allez me dire on peut pas moi
j'étais mère de mon petit village dans
limousin 320 habitants mon successeur
vous savez combien d'embauchés de
cantonniers pour 300 habitants trois
cantonniers
c'est dingue oui c'est pour offrir
alors bien sûr c'était des gens qui
étaient il vaut mieux qu'ils soient
cantonniers plutôt qu'au chômage
vaut-il mieux qu'ils sont cantonniers
plutôt qu'au chômage je suis pas sûr je
pense qu'il vaut mieux qu'ils soient au
chômage et que les lois nous permettent
de réduire le chômage en france et c'est
ce que j'appelais tout à l'heure de mes
voeux avec la flexibilité du marché du
travail et autorisons rêvons un peu
autorisons un plan de licenciement
économique de 2 3 à 4 5 % de l'effectif
sans autre forme de procès que de passer
par une info consul quatre mois plus le
développe sa fluidifierait
formidablement l'été par il faut après
fluidifier les arrivées mais si on peut
libérer le travail comme ça on peut
aussi embauché donc je crois que c'est
ccc des freins là qu'il faut sur
lesquels il faut travailler les
ordonnances pénicaud vont plutôt dans le
bon sens mais vous rappeler le programme
de macron dans son dans son élection il
prêt il préconisait de supprimer le
pouvoir des branches il a fait beaucoup
de choses dans ce domaine sauf les
branches
or les branches et 1 700 en france et
c'est ça qui est qui et qui sclérosent
beaucoup les négociations d'entreprise
nous pouvons prendre une dernière
question juste une question c'est ans
d'union de d'élections européennes qui
arrive bientôt votre position sur le
site
est ce que vous en pensez
même si c'est pas vrai pendant la
restructuration en même temps on en
parle un peu en europe
quelle tristesse pour les anglais mais
quelle tristesse pour nous c'est c'est
un truc perdant-perdant et moi j'observe
que la démocratie qui fonctionne le
mieux en europe
stern allemagne n'a pas dans sa
constitution l'accès au référendum temps
et est du coup n'a pas la tentation
d'émettre une question à laquelle les
électeurs vont répondre de façon et bien
sûr biaisé
quelle tristesse elle entend le monde
financier qui est celui de mes clients
parce que la plupart de mes clients sont
des fonds qui demandent d'intervenir
quand la société va mal tous ces fonds
se rapatrie et aux us
pas tellement en europe continentale à
singapour à dubaï et c est le pari
centre de du monde est en train de
quitter l'europe de façon extrêmement
clair la boussole du monde et elle elle
est affolée elle est affolante
mais quand même elle indique l'est faut
aller vers l'est
merci infiniment je vraiment je remercie
patrick puis parce que il a fait
l'effort d'être parmi nous alors qu'il
est vraiment demandé ailleurs et il a
tenu sa parole est vraiment je le
remercie beaucoup pour ça et merci pour
ce témoignage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]